hello my name is dr anu anand
i'm going to be giving a informational
session about medical marijuana and cbd
and expanding acceptance and use by
physicians
a little bit about myself
i am a physician board certified in
physical medicine and rehabilitation
i practice in pittsburgh pennsylvania
and
manage a practice where i manage
patients with ms
you know chronic pain from spinal cord
injuries
amputees uh stroke patients so a lot of
spasticity
joint pains and have been practicing
here in pittsburgh four years
otherwise i've been practicing close to
10 years past residency
i have published in multiple
peer-reviewed journals as well as
books for physical medicine and rehab i
also incidentally have
a company that produces
cbd for my patients so that is why i'm
interested in
giving a lecture and learning more about
medical marijuana and cbd in the
cannabis space
so some learning objectives one
potentially
whatever potential benefits for medical
marijuana and cbd are there for patients
understanding the adverse effects and
drug interactions of thc and cbd in
patients
and reviewing current evidence and
condition considering additional
research needs
to support the therapeutic use of thc
and cbd
so few of the discussion topics will be
going over
are the legal and research barriers with
both cbd and medical marijuana
barriers to physicians prescribing for
medical use
and physician and patient engagement to
help us
kind of expand that use and make it more
acceptable
so first regarding the legal and
research barriers
you know there is definitely an
increased role
of cannabis in treating medical
conditions mostly spurred by
patients rather than physicians and
there's a rapidly evolving
attitude toward cannabis and expanding
legalization for medical
and recreational use and i have these
two slides here
one of them is regarding the cannabis
retail
estimates from 2018 to 2030
and you can see that it's just
increasing
almost 54 each year and that's a
huge amount of you know growth every
year
and it looks like it's almost close to 2
billion in 2020 for
cbd sales and again for the
one on the right it shows total u.s cbd
sales from 2014 to
2020 expected growth and it's
exponential so
as more and more people are becoming
accepting of it
and there's more products on the market
the more physicians are going to
experience
and have to interact with cbd and
medical marijuana
and be able to provide patients some
more
education and appropriate response and
guidance on how to use and
you know possibly treat with these
products
differences between cbd and thc
this is a part that many physicians are
actually kind of confused on
because in medical school and residency
or wherever else in training
we really only see it as you know weed
or
marijuana and we know thc and cbd on a
you know chemical component standpoint
but in terms of what it's a potential
effects
um side effects and where these actually
come from
most of us are not as educated so
some basics are that you know hemp
products
is mostly cbd heavy and marijuana
products are more really
more thc ready or thc heavy
they're both um derived from the same
cannabis sativa
plant and hemp is just less than
point zero three percent thc
and the thc is the one that's
psychoactive and cbd is not which means
it can cause
you know the high sensation confusion
and
feelings of euphoria so outside
and those are two very distinct things
um which i'll come to at the next point
regarding the differences between
marijuana and hemp and
its application currently for patients
and
legal problems with both and
you know again one of the real
differences between cbd and thc they're
very similar types of components
but cbd acts at
cb1 receptors which those receptors
produce
a sense of relaxation and have
applications for both pain and anxiety
for both
you know what are the effects for both
not fully understood some are
helpful for pain relief some are helpful
for anxiety some help for
spasticity and it's really deciphering
which one helps more for
certain things um
next up for medical applications how can
they be applied
are some you know useful for migraine
headaches are some
useful for glaucoma which one and how
much and then also understanding the
side effects of
both of these
so next on legal and research barriers
are an adequate understanding
for optimal intervention so again
cannabis marijuana is a schedule
one controlled substances so that means
there's different levels and barriers to
what can be prescribed as a controlled
substance schedule
one is the most restrictive that means
there's
really no reason to use it
in medical practice and then
but the caveat is that obviously some
have been studied
and we do have some thc and cbd products
that are now schedule three
that means they are still you know
restricted and require
some you know close management by a
physician
but they're scheduled three whereas you
know schedule two
are common medications people know such
as percocet and oxycodone
and fentanyl um schedule three are
marinol and um even
at the dialects which is a schedule four
so it's even less restrictive
so um this is just some of the shifts
and how
clinicians need to understand that you
know there's thc products cbd products
and which you know how much restriction
and how much
control we need in able to being able to
prescribe these to our patients
so that is something that will need to
be worked on and
in this table you can see that
epidiolex is a schedule four it's used
for treating very specific
seizures marinol which um i actually do
prescribe to patients
with appetite and some pain related
issues especially if they have cancer
so it's actually found in our hospitals
when i need to prescribe it i can
actually order it from a pharmacy
and then um casemet which is
schedule two medication and it's not as
widely used but also to help with
cancer related chemotherapy pain
and appetite now sativex is not approved
for
us use but there are ways to get around
it
there are patients that are able to have
access to it here in the us
next up is understanding the disease
states which
it could be used for um and could be
beneficial for
so a few of the things again there's so
many
areas that are not understood for both
physicians and even just in general
because there's a lot to learn about
you know thc cbd marijuana and all of
its
substrates so one is
how is it metabolized in the body one of
the key enzymes in our bodies called
cytochrome p450
it's a liver enzyme that breaks down and
metabolizes some of the drugs we use
seizure drugs antibacterials or
antibiotics
a lot of pain medications so it can make
it stronger or weaker
so you have to change your dosing when
you're using cbd
and marijuana products so that's you
know always a concern we don't know how
much to modify it
and where you know we can add these
medications safely into a patient's
regimen
so and this key group of enzymes
metabolizes more than
60 of marketed meds so that's a big
consideration to see the cross
reactivity for
physicians to see is it safe enough to
give my patients and how much
so you can see i have some tables here
that are
drug drug interactions for thc thc
and cbd and just cbd alone and
they're all pretty similar especially
for
antidepressants or any cns depressant
medication
that's the main thing that we have to
look out for
so you can see on the table to the right
for cbd
other substrates cbda cbg
thcv they all have different
mechanisms and different things that
they do to the body
some are antibacterial some believe
anxiety
some promote bone growth some treat
fungal infection
some help with inhibits cancer cell
growth
so there's so many options and there's a
lot of
things to learn about it going forward
and
there's just you know a lot that
patients could probably
teach a physician
next one as i mentioned before the drug
drug intervention
is really the the biggest concern you
know
most patients that are looking for
medical use
or ha are on complex medications some on
you know very expensive and dangerous
chemotherapy medications
most patients that for my personal use
want to use it to
reduce their opioids or get off their
opioids
and you know i always worry if you're
using it
how is it going to affect it is it going
to make it so that you're feeling more
drowsy is it going to aggravate your
stomach
it's it's kind of hard to tell um except
with experience and
you know managing these patients
carefully
that's just um another thing to think
about and
have two tables um you know one on the
left is just talking about the potential
side effects with the antibiotics as an
anti-cancer ones
and the table on the right you know
there's just so many different
medications such as hal dolls and baltha
valium
and heart rate medications and blood
thinners that
we need to look out for
so next are research and future of
medical marijuana and cbd
so again i mentioned there's different
receptors in the body
that react differently to these
compounds
they help with different things some
receptors help with
as i mentioned anxiety pain spasms
which are cb1 and cb2 receptors
thc mostly reacts at cb1
and that causes the psychoactive
component and cbd
has little activity there but mostly
activates cb2
receptors so there's different
effects of the thc and cbd even though
they do have some
overall similar components in
helping being able to help patients most
of them are the anti-inflammatory and
immunomodular effects
next you know cardiovascular effects
there is a lot of stuff to be studied
there it might
decrease blood pressure and so there's
some studies that show that it might
influence myocardial infarcts which are
heart attacks
next for appetite some stimulate you
know
appetite and some slow gut motility
which could be very helpful to someone
with
gi issues such as crohn's or ulcerative
colitis
so for carcinogenesis i want to look at
patients that
might have some malignancy you know
there's some studies that it could
potentially help
with lung cancer again very prelim
studies
and then for ephthalmagic conditions it
can
lower intraocular pressure and glaucoma
which one is one of the main conditions
that we see for medical marijuana use
next up legalization and classification
so again now marijuana remains the
schedule one substance so that means
doing research on it this is very
limited very difficult
to get a hold of very difficult to get
you know university institutions and you
know
physicians and patients to want to
participate in any of these studies
for example some other you know schedule
1 substances are heroin
lsd and ecstasy outside of marijuana
and hemp-based cbd as i mentioned is
very confusing
because the fda doesn't validate
or outside of one or two prescription
medications it hasn't really
given a clear all or
guidance on how to kind of go about
doing cbd
research as well a lot of the cbd
research is done with pure cbd not
necessarily hemp oils
so the consistency is also lacking and
for marijuana 36 states including
dc guam puerto rico and u.s virgin
islands have approved it
um and is available so that's a there's
more than
you know 50 of the us that has this
available to them
but you know again there's definitely
not 50 percent of physicians that are
you are prescribing it or can give
guidance on it
so this is the legal aspects
to prescribing both medical marijuana
and cbd
where medical marijuana is legal doctors
can write a recommendation
you cannot write a prescription like
when you come to the office and your
ears aching you write a
antibiotic i can't hand you a
prescription it is just a recommendation
saying yes you are someone that
is recommended to be a candidate
for medical marijuana but i can't tell
you how much i can't tell you
how to use it it's not
a prescription now there was some
concern about
how this is done because there was
a court order from the u.s court of
appeals
showing that physicians discussing
potential benefits
is freedom of speech so that at least
rule and support was given again each
state has different conditions approved
there's limited clarity
and continued confusion on what states
approve
which diagnosis as this changes
frequently
and for doctors are really reluctant to
say
oh you should use a drop you should use
a cream
i can't tell you what dosing i can't
tell you which strain
because it's also vague and
you know there's no consistency between
dispensary and physicians
and some states do require physician and
patient clinical
relationships before prescribing
again if you are trying to get it from a
physician that doesn't believe in it or
doesn't think it's for you
you're kind of stuck you have to end up
trying to find a new physician that
might be willing to prescribe medical
marijuana or discuss cbd with you
and there's also limited physician
training on laws and dosing
of both cbd and medical marijuana
so most common questions for physicians
are how do you regulate it how do you
recommend it how do you
dispense it registering patients finding
out exactly what they're using
those can be quite confusing to
physicians
and examples of diagnoses for states
these are some of the diagnoses that
are approved for medical marijuana and
i'm live in pennsylvania currently
there's
23 qualifying conditions but in 2018
there are 17.
we cannot prescribe edibles previously
smoking was prohibited now there's
flower use so
again things are just rapidly changing
and it's
another thing to keep up with but we're
not you know given this literature
usually like we are with new medications
and new drugs
i'm not reading it in you know jama
every month about what the new updates
of medical marijuana are
or cbd so uh cbd
or sorry for thc and medical marijuana
the pharmacists and the dispensaries
that actually have most control over
what to help a patient with which
medications to give
a lot of states require pharmacists to
consult with the patients
and again the thc cbd ratios and various
strains are inconsistent
some states allow certain things and
some don't allow others so
a lot of confusion
some other barriers are cbd research and
questions that require further
investigation
during the approval process for
epidiolex
there are some potential side effects
and this is what everyone's kind of
concerned about when they read about cbd
liver injury what is the dosing that
causes it
you know interactions other medications
the increased risk of sedation
causing drowsiness and can they mix with
medications that
treat your anxiety and panic and sleep
disorders such as
ambien do they change your alertness do
they
cause appetite issues and some were are
the epidialex is
known to cause some diarrhea so those
are some questions
so what happens with prolonged use of
cbd and thc what happens with certain
dosing we don't know what the triggers
are
what is the best way to take it should
someone be smoking it
probably not and then for physicians and
then
is you know orally is that the best way
or topical
you know those are still to be
understood what happens in developing
brain
how does it affect it how does it affect
breastfeeding moms and developing babies
and breastfed babies
and does cbd affect male fertility there
is some studies that show that
you know marijuana use can affect male
fertility
next there's just an abundance of
products out on the market
that we can choose from i honestly don't
even know how many there are i'm sure
there's literally hundreds coming out
every month
and most of those are put to market with
little or no research
there's issues on trust quality and
consistency of products
many times the dosage is not known or
verified by third parties
what are the side effects again which is
the best form
do you take the pill version you take
the tincture you use a cream
a lot of people and physicians and
patients see it as recreational they
don't maybe consider it as
a therapeutic product and
we'll i know as a physician i don't
prescribe what's unknown or
you know could be potentially damaging
or
you know unsafe for a patient and
you know people where are you getting
this product from amazon unknown markets
your
neighbor and even for pets these are
this
example bottles of just what's even out
there for your pet and for
human use it's even more you know
obviously for my pet
i would be concerned about what i'm
putting in them and just like
you know for humans what are we putting
into our bodies
so how do we kind of come to a solution
how do we
make this more acceptable and you know
solve some of these key issues one is
that
we need more research research that fda
can back and approve an irb which means
independent review board which is a
third party that makes sure your
research
is you know following all the guidelines
so physicians need to be educated on the
current benefits
and the risks side effects and
all of this and patients need to
advocate for themselves
sometimes they need to see that research
and bring it to their physicians to say
i want you to look at this and tell me
what you think
that's one of the things i would
recommend and
you know issues that further need you
know
engagement is that the research that's
out there
there's not a lot it's not qualified
and results um in current patients are
very minimal most more animal based or
just based on
the biology of it and the chemistry
rather than
in patients research and tracking
symptoms
that what symptoms and what diagnosis
could potentially benefit there again
there's
skin conditions diabetes hypertension
that's a whole new realm
that most patients don't even realize
physicians don't realize that it could
help
astigmatism marijuana versus cbd
schedule one
schedule three you know what's the
legality of it
and again with dosing how much is this
the right
dosing is it the right amount do i take
it once a day twice a day
um so other solutions are you know
patients rely on physician for
information on thc and cbd
products and physicians don't know and
they rely on
you know patients and it's a taboo
[Music]
topic so a lot of patients won't even
bring it up because they're nervous that
their physician is going to judge them
for it
and you know big pharma they can come
into physicians offices they can come
into medical
conferences and say here learn about my
drug these are all the side effect
profiles this is why you should use it
this is what you need to worry about
but marijuana and cbd companies don't
have that access
to physicians and to the medical
community in a whole
they're not approaching them saying can
you learn about this and see what his
potential
or your patience could be and this is in
our experience what we've known the side
effects they don't have that opportunity
so there's a huge barrier that needs to
be crossed
there needs to be better operators who
produce you know quality ingredients and
quality products
and maybe can promote some research and
allow it to be
you know presented to patients and
medical providers
um so that was kind of where i came up
with my own solution after many years of
patients
asked me about alternatives for
marijuana and cbd if you asked me five
years ago i would have said
absolutely not but then seeing patients
presenting things to me presenting
literature presenting their products
and me taking a closer look and seeing
that
some patients were doing very well on
these products so when
i you know started to prescribe medical
marijuana and notice improvement in my
patients
the ones that didn't want to pursue
marijuana or couldn't use it for
medical reasons we looked in the cbd
and then we started testing the products
and seeing the inconsistencies
and again i didn't know where they were
getting it from
or what the lab data showed so
i teamed up with a group called hemp
synergistics
and they helped produce products from me
that i formulated the dosing based on
recent current research that's out there
and you know how much is needed for
transport for skin-based therapy
or oral tincture based and
produced a pill based form that helps
bypass a gut so it's more bioavailable
so i started using that
currently right now we're in the process
of working with the fda and irb to do
some research
studies on these and seeing how my
patients on
chronic opioid therapies do with this
product and see if they're able to
reduce any of their opioid use
so hopefully this will allow some more
clarity and acceptance
into the medical communities there is
products that fit all those criteria
that physicians are looking for
so um all my patients have access to
this product
and i'm able to oversee their you know
medical care
medications while they're using it so i
i think they're seeing a lot of good
effects so far and i'm hoping that
the you know cannabis and cbd industry
in the future
will be able to do more things like this
and provide
you know more opportunities for patients
to get relief
and this last slide is you know the
products that i'm currently
allowing my patients to use and seeing
how they're doing on it and that we're
doing our research on
i think that's it um thank you all for
your time and
i appreciate being a part of this
conference